engen's Origins rexy's Legacy and an
oddly High number of reconciling couples
we're digging deep to an Earth for finer
points of the entire Jurassic Park
franchise how'd you do this
65 million years ago the late Cretaceous
Period met the Paleo Gene period this
marked a sudden mass extinction of three
quarters of the animals and plants on
Earth including all dinosaurs in a
prologue for Jurassic world Dominion
that was cut from the final version
viewers are introduced to a host of
dinosaurs like the dreadnoughtus the
Morrow's intrepidus both of which have
been previously unseen in the franchise
at the end of the prologue the last
dinosaur to be introduced is a
giganotosaurus the largest apex predator
of all time and it quickly asserts its
dominance over Tyrannosaurus Rex this
scene isn't only significant because a
genetically engineered version of the
Giganotosaurus returns reclaim that
title later in the film though it also
links back to the scene in the first
Jurassic Park film When Alan Ellie and
Ian watch a short film about a mosquito
getting encased in Amber and fossilized
after drinking the blood of a dinosaur
Bingo Dino dma the prologue heavily
suggests that it was this mosquito or
rather one like it that was later used
by John Hammond and Sir Benjamin
Lockwood's company Indian to extract
dinosaur DNA and then create the T-Rex
in the 1980s by 1969 John Hammond had
made his vested interest in animals very
clear having opened his first animal
preserved Animal Kingdom that year in
Nairobi Kenya he also hires future
Jurassic Park employee Robert Muldoon to
work there as a park Warden but taking
care of and showcasing animals already
on the planet clearly isn't enough for
Hammond and he soon sets out to bring
dinosaurs back into the modern world
having dreamed up the idea of using the
DNA of creatures in case the number like
the mosquito to clone extinct animals he
starts working with a small research
team calling his company the Hammond
foundation in 1975 Hammond has secured
enough investors and the partnership
with British entrepreneur sir Benjamin
Lockwood together they found
International genetic Technologies a
bioengineering company more commonly
referred to as Indian working out of a
laboratory in Lockwood's basement the
paired teams up with scientists and
conducts research on bringing extinct
animals back to life here they make
plans for a dinosaur theme park which
they named Jurassic Park in 1982 in gen
signs a 99-year long lace for Isla sauna
and the muates archipelago from the
Costa Rican government where they plan
to conduct research and construction
begins on Jurassic Park San Diego in
1984 almost a decade after founding
engine John Hammond and Sir Benjamin
Lockwood have their first major
breakthrough still working out of
Lockwood's estate he Hammonds and their
team of scientists beginner
fertilization test on an artificial ovum
which is successful a year later they
moved their headquarters to Palo Alto
and successfully cloned the prehistoric
DNA from the Amber both other changes
are a foot at Indian as hamon suspends
construction on Jurassic Park San Diego
indefinitely instead he looks to move
the park to Isla nubla in Costa Rica in
gen leads to the island from the Costa
Rican government adding it to the
99-year lease that already agreed to now
making use of the islands they leased
engine starts working on Isla sauna
which they call site B but they haven't
been able to clone a dinosaur yet
despite having success with the Amber in
1986 Hammond and Lockwood and Dr Henry
Wu to their team Auntie suggests they
splice the DNA of dinosaurs of that of
modern animals like frogs shortly
afterward ingen successfully clones her
first dinosaur a Triceratops Wu also
comes up with the lysine contingency a
plant that would theoretically protect
the humans if the dinosaurs ever escaped
by adding a faulty Gene to the dinosaurs
they've become dependent on supplemental
lysine that ingen gave them removing
dinosaurs from captivity then will
deprive them of the enriched food send
the dinosaurs into a coma and ultimately
kill them now seeing signs have never
been progress with its ability to
genetically engineer and replicate
dinosaurs ingen goes ahead with plans
for a new Jurassic Park on Isla nubla
which they refer to as site a
construction begins on the Island in
1988 and has finished in 1993. during
this period Indian successfully hatches
more dinosaurs including the
Tyrannosaurus Rex Rexy who was seen
throughout the Jurassic Park and
Jurassic World movies Rexy is born on
site B Bert has moved over to a paddock
on Isla nubla in 1989 when she's one
year old ngn has other Innovative
success thanks to Dr Henry Wu who
realizes that the DNA of the yellow
poisoned dart frog they've been using is
incompatible with some dinosaur genomes
like Velociraptors He suggests ingen
uses the read frog although any
geneticist should suspect that since the
read frog can change sex his ability
could be passed down to the dinosaurs
it's ignored and is later the reason the
dinosaurs have been able to reproduce a
reveal scene in Jurassic Park and
expanded upon in the Lost World of
Jurassic Park Wu also researches the
hybridization of dinosaurs during this
period which of course will eventually
lead to the indominus Rex however ingen
also suffers a major blow when sir
Benjamin Lockwood leaves the company
after he and John Hammond fall out
although the cause for this is not known
in Jurassic Park as retconned into the
story in Jurassic world Dominion in this
latest installment of the franchise we
learned that Hammond was disgusted by
Lockwood's interest in using their
research for human cloning after his
daughter Charlotte who worked on either
the sauna revealed she wished to have a
baby this way just like blue Charlotte
was able to have a child all by herself
she created you
with our own DNA despite that Benjamin
Lockwood's Apache from Indian John
Hammond forges ahead with his plan to
open Jurassic Park on Isla nubla however
the company's board of directors has
concerns about the Park's safety after
gatekeeper Joffrey Brown is killed by a
velociraptor while transferring them to
a higher security holding pen and his
family susinjan nevertheless Hammond
believes Jurassic Park is the perfect
place to bring his grandchildren Lex and
Tim to get their minds off their parents
divorce lawyer Donald janaro also heads
to ease the nublar to assess the
weaknesses of the park and whether or
not operations should be shut down
before the park even opens he brings
along Dr Ian Malcolm for another
expert's opinion our scientists have
done things which nobody's ever done
before yeah yeah but your scientists
were so preoccupied with whether or not
they could they didn't start to think
they should in response Hammond invites
Dr Alan Grant and Dr Ellie Sadler along
hoping they will endorse the bug
elsewhere Lewis dodgson meets the
Jurassic Park computer programmer Dennis
nedry and convinces him to steal
dinosaur embryos for rival company
biosin in exchange for 1.5 million
dollars
on June 11th everyone arrives at the
park and the events of the first
Jurassic Park film take place over the
next 48 hours John Hammond takes Alan
Grant Ellie Satler Ian Malcolm and
Donald Gennaro on a tour of Jurassic
Park where they can see brachiosaurus
and Parasaurolophus Dinosaurs the group
is later joined by Lex and Tim but they
see very few other dinosaurs that
afternoon an unexpected tropical storm
heading toward is the new blood and
forces all non-essential Personnel to be
evacuated leaving only nedri Hammond
Robert Muldoon and Ray Arnold to manage
the park Ninja soon sneaks off to steal
the embryos and shuts down all power and
security protocols on the island except
for the Velociraptor holding pen this
allows Rexy to escape her Paddock and
attack Lex Tim Ian and Alan and Donald
suffers one of the most memorable deaths
in cinema history
the same goes for nedry who doesn't
quite make it off the island with all of
his stolen embryos thanks to a run-in
with a spunky Dilophosaurus in a bid to
reverse nedri's actions and get the
power back on Rey does a full system
reset but this deactivates the Raptor's
Paddock it's not long before Rey and
Robert are both devoured by the Raptors
this leaves Alan Ellie Ian Hammond Lex
and Tim to get the power back on and
call for help they eventually do do this
but they encounter the Raptors several
more times before being saved by Rexy by
the end of the film even John concurs
Jurassic Park can't be saved and the
survivors escaping a helicopter the Lost
World Jurassic Park Begins by filling in
the gaps of the past four years since
Engen abandoned is La nubla during this
period the bioengineering company is hit
with more lawsuits for the wrongful
deaths of Donald Gennaro Robert Muldoon
and Ray Arnold which they covered up and
are nearly bankrupt because of it
because of this John Hammond is fired by
the board and his nephew Peter Ludlow
who places him as CEO he makes plans to
open Jurassic Park San Diego and wants
to move over dinosaurs from site B there
are plenty because as Dr Henry Wu
discovered the lysine contingency had
proven ineffective and the remaining
dinosaurs began breeding Dr Ian Malcolm
breaks his non-disclosure agreement with
ingen to raise awareness over the events
of Isla nubla but is discredited by
Ludlow despite this he initially refuses
Hammond's request for him to go to site
B with a small group of experts and
document the dinosaurs there and stop in
Jen from profiting off them however he
changes his mind when his girlfriend Dr
Sarah Harding is part of the group and
already on the island he follows her
there to rescue her but soon discovers
his teenage daughter Kelly has stowed
away on the rescue mission too Herman's
team the gatherers race against ingen's
Hunters but are ultimately forced to
work together after three dinosaurs and
a pair of rexes destroy their vehicles
and communication equipment after
several encounters with the buck Rex his
female counterparts and some
Velociraptors the gatherers escaped the
island but ludlow's men capture the bar
can take him to San Diego Ian and Sarah
use a young T-Rex Junior to lure him
back onto the cargo ship the Ship Sails
back to Isla sauna but not before Junior
eats Ludlow following the events of
Islam sauna and in San Diego John
Hammond petitions a government to have
Isla sauna left as a nature reserve for
the Dinosaurs the U.S House Committee of
science also passes the gene guard act
which gives bioengineered Dinosaurs the
same status and rights as endangered
species as a result access to the
islands is restricted and India is
forbidden from cloning any other
prehistoric Flora or fauna this seems to
be the end of ingen's Jurassic Adventure
but when Hammond dies shortly after the
events of lost world masrani global
swoops in and acquires the
bioengineering firm having taken over
from his father as the CEO of masrani
global in 1992 Simon marzrani has kept a
watchful eye over Hammond's company for
years after taking over engine in 1998
masrani sets out to fulfill Hammond's
failed dream of opening Jurassic Park
this time renamed Jurassic world
breaking the gene guard act he starts
experimenting me and months after
Hammond's death shortly after ingen
begins secret experiments on site B with
a goal of a legally breed new species
including the super Predator Spinosaurus
plans for a new park are underway and in
1999 the ungrounds masrani global legal
but limited access to Isla sauna Simon
brings Dr Henry Wu into his new Jurassic
world project in 2000 who eventually
becomes a lead genetic biologist to
Indian Jurassic Park 3 begins by
revealing what Alan Grant and Ellie
Sadler have been doing in the eight
years since they were on Isla nubla
notably Ellie has retired from paleo
botany although the two remain close
Ellie is now married to Mark degler who
works at the state department and they
have two young children together
meanwhile Alan remains active in the
field of paleontology in the beginning
of the film we see him and his Protege
Billy Brennan testing the Prototype of a
machine that's able to craft an accurate
replica of a Velociraptor voice box
wow
this is brilliant Billy it's here at
this worksite the wealthy thrill-seeking
couple Paul and Amanda Kirby approach
Alan and offer to fun further research
if he gives them and free mercenaries an
aerial tour of Isla nubla Alan
reluctantly agrees and brings Billy
along with him but the Kirby's ulterior
motive is soon revealed as the couple
actually plans to rescue their son Eric
who along with Amanda's boyfriend have
been Hildebrand has got a missing on
Isla sauna after an illegal parasailing
tour over the island on the island Alan
finds Eric now the sole survivor and
reunites him with his parents their
group faces attacks from Velociraptors
to Rhino dance and the Spinosaurus and
all three of the mercenaries are killed
one by one Alan gets out to distress
call to Ellie and Mark though who send
the rescue team while Alan fakes a
distress call with his Raptor voice box
to help them Escape Billy believed to be
dead is later rescued by the U.S Marines
as a result of Alan and the Kirby's
actions on Isla sauna a group of
pteranodons escape and the spa spotted
over British Columbia however Simon
masrani hired security contractor Vic
Hoskins to deal with them after doing
this he has subsequently hired as
ingen's head of security these events
hadn't put masrani off opening his new
Park Jurassic world and in 2002 a year
after Helen's harrowing visit to Isla
sauna masrani announces his plans to the
world he also has Rexy and the other
Rogue dinosaurs recaptured on Isla nubla
they are shipped to site B until their
enclosures in the new park are finished
in 2003 Indian bribes members of the U.S
House Committee of science who then
agreed to remove the restrictions on
ingen because of the gene guard act
which allows them to begin cloning and
genetically engineering new species of
dinosaurs for Jurassic world the
following year Simon Mars Rani hires
Claire Deering as an intern on the
Jurassic world project Maserati Global
Corporation soon begins moving the
dinosaurs back from site B to the new
park on site a at the time as Ronnie's
company is credited with saving the
creatures from ecological disaster it's
later revealed in 2015 that the strain
on the Isla sauna ecosystem had actually
been caused by ingen's secret
experiments on Isla sauna in 1998 and
masrani acquired the company
in 2005 Simon Maserati's company opens
its new Dinosaur Park Jurassic world to
the public elsewhere just a few short
years later sir Benjamin Lockwood's
daughter Charlotte has succeeded in
cloning herself her daughter Maisie is
born while Charlotte suffers from a rare
genetic disease that leads to her death
in 2009 Claire continues rising to the
ranks of Indian she eventually becomes a
senior assets manager at Jurassic world
we've learned more from genetics in the
past decade Than A Century of Digging Up
Bones work on the indominus Rex begins
in 2012 after demands from Jurassic
world's Board of investors caused Clara
masrani to ask Dr Henry Wu to create a
hybrid theropod developments in dinosaur
Behavior at Jurassic world continue with
Owen Grady selected to head up a special
project at its head Velociraptor trainer
Delta I see you back up foreign
during this time as Rani authorizes the
construction of a new facility in
Siberia in 2012 which opens in 2014. its
focus is to extract the DNA of animals
from the Ice Age on Isla nublar in 2012
a new pack of Velociraptors is
engineered by Wu's team and the Raptors
blue charlie delta and Echo are born in
2013 Owen recognizes some nuances in the
dynamic of their pack and requests that
his friend Barry Sam Ben joined his team
by 2015 Jurassic world has operated for
10 years without incident in 2015 Simon
masrani publicly announced that Jurassic
world will soon be unveiling a new
genetically engineered dinosaur the
indominus Rex it tried to break the
glass
I like a spirit as a result ticket sales
rise astronomically meanwhile Claire
deering's nephews Zack and gray Mitchell
come to visit her on Isla nubla while
their parents go through divorce
proceedings their arrival coincides if
Jurassic world's first big disaster the
indominus Rex which ate its twin when it
was younger is much smarter than Indian
scientists expected and displays traits
that even Dr Henry Wu its creator is
surprised by its camouflage abilities
along with its significant intelligence
allow it to escape innocent suing
Rampage nearly kills Owen and its
Carnage throughout the park causes mass
chaos destruction and further dinosaur
escapes Claire and Owen team up to
search for Zack and gray who briefly
encountered the indominus on their
gyrosphere ride meanwhile the Tirana
dance Escape their enclosure when
Maserati's helicopter sends the
indominus Rex into the paddock he dies
when tuna dance and dimorphodons fly
into the helicopter and it crashes then
realizing that Extreme Measures need to
be taken Owen uses Blues pack to Hunts
the your boyfriend's a badass
to Haze and the others dismay they
initially side with her sensing her
Velociraptor DNA however Owen eventually
gets through to Blue and she helps them
fight the indominus with the help of
Rexy and a surprise assist from the
mosasaurus the group defeats the
indominus despite a lot of death all's
well that ends well Zack and Gray's
parents return to get them together
seemingly no longer getting divorced
while Claire and Owen walk off into the
sunset season 1 of Jurassic world combo
Cretaceous takes place simultaneously to
the events of Jurassic world beginning
just before Jack and gray arrive on Isla
nubla a group of six kids Darius Ben Yaz
Brooklyn Kenji and Sami arrive on the
island to attend adventure camp however
they discover problems within the park
and end up having several close
encounters with Dinosaurs like the
Carnotaurus however before their many
near-death experiences Claire Deering
actually planned for a nephews to attend
this camp but the Council of Roxy
suggested it would be too much to take
on a season 1 Progressive is the campers
are attacked by the indominus Rex and
the mosasaurus which makes them Miss to
Ferry off Isla nubla leaving them
stranded on the Island season 2 picks up
after the events of Jurassic world with
the islands now orbit abandoned while
trying to avoid getting killed by
Dinosaurs the kids face off against new
characters Mitch and Tiff who have come
to the island claiming to be ego Taurus
but instead are Hunters looking to bag
some dinosaur trophies of course they
both get what's coming to them with Rexy
taking a bite out of Midge and stiff
being killed by the Baryonyx Duo chaos
and limbo Jurassic world come Cretaceous
season 3 lines up with the opening scene
of Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom which
is set six months after the events of
Jurassic world Dr Henry Wu was just
started working for sir Benjamin
Lockwood's estate manager Eli Mills and
they've sent a group of mercenaries to
recover the bones of indominus Rex the
Animated Series recreates pieces of this
opening scene before depicting what else
was going on around the island it
notably reveals that Wu engineered two
times types of hybrid dinosaurs he
created the Scorpius Rex before the
indominus but Simon masrani ordered Wu
to have her kill because she was too
terrifying for the park however he
didn't do this instead placing the
dinosaur into a cryofreeze chamber and
planning to use her to create his next
hybrid she has accidentally Freed at the
end of season two and after a sexually
procreating between the second and third
Seasons she and her child attacked the
campus several times they face off
against the campers for the last time in
the old Jurassic Park visitor's center
in the episode escape from Isla nubla
where the dinosaurs are killed when the
roof caves in afterward in season 4 the
campers finally escaped from Isla nubla
back on the mainland Wu receives the
indominus Rex DNA The Mercenaries
recovered from Isla nubla and Engineers
a new dinosaur called the indoraptor the
following year Claire Deering founds a
dinosaur protection Group after Isla
nublar's volcano Mount sibo becomes
active and threatens to kill all the
dinosaurs in June 2018 Claire Deering is
summoned to Sir Benjamin Lockwood's
estate where he introduced himself as an
old associate of John Hammonds he offers
to fund our rescue mission to ease the
nubla so that she can save the dinosaurs
from Extinction as Mount sibo is now
erupting however he requests that are
now ex-boyfriend Owen Grady also joined
the mission as he's the only one who can
save blue check for more huh
can I buy you beer
you bring them or do we like go
somewhere Clara and Owen returned to the
island along with paleo veterinarian Zia
Rodriguez and I.T expert Franklin Webb
to their surprise they are met by
mercenary and Trophy Hunter Ken Wheatley
who double crosses them and captures
blue after a few close encounters with
dinosaurs under near drowning Claire
Owen Zia and Franklin escape the island
and stow away on board one of wheatley's
ships where they are taken back to the
Lockwood estate Benjamin has just died
at the hands of Ellie Mills who has
subsequently taken control locking
Lockwood's granddaughter Maisie in her
room and going ahead with his plans to
bankroll further genetic research Claire
and Owen discovered that Dr Wu has
created a new hybrid called the
indoraptor furthermore Mills is
auctioning off dinosaurs to the highest
bidder Burton typical Jurassic fashion
this deadly dinosaur doesn't remain in
its cage for long and kills several of
the guests before attacking Maisie With
a Little Help from Blue Claire Owen and
Maisie eventually tricked the
indo-raptor so it falls through the
glass roof impales itself Mills is
killed in the chaos of the Mansion but
when the group is faced with gas
potentially killing all the dinosaurs
within the Mansion Maisie makes a choice
to let them all go free I had to
their life
like me one year after Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom dinosaurs have spread
across North America and humans begin to
encounter them more and more and it's
not long before they spread across the
entire world this is shown in the short
film basil at Big Rock which gives
viewers an insight into what this new
world looks like centered around one
family of Campers at Big Rock National
Park it begins when a mother and baby
nesuto ceratops wander around their
campfire the Human family joins an
assuto ceratops mother and her mate in a
fight against the Allosaurus and it
eventually leaves when the young
daughter shoots it with a crossbow the
film depicts just one of the many
encounters humans now have with
dinosaurs and is a precursor to what
comes in Jurassic world Dominion but
before the Epic finale can take place
the Jurassic Park timeline jumps over to
the campers on Manticore Island season 5
of Jurassic Park crime Cretaceous leads
directly into the third Jurassic world
film reestablishing Lewis dodgson's
character voiced by Adam Harrington in
the animated series and played by
Campbell Scott and Dominion the CEO of
biosin is the main antagonist for the
remainder of the franchise although the
campus foiled his attempt to use mind
control chips on all the dinosaurs on
the island he gets away with the
technology which will soon come into
play Ellie satlow and Alan Grant reunite
in Jurassic world Dominion as Lewis
Dodge son invites them to tour his
biostin facility where Ian Malcolm now
works with help from Ian and Ramsey Cole
they quickly discovered that Dodson and
Henry Wu have been genetically
engineering a swarm of prehistoric giant
Locus to destroy all crops except the
ones grown with biosin seeds however Wu
needs Maisie Lockwood's DNA to fix a
genetic defect in the locus so dodgson
has her in Blue's child beta kidnapped
from the Sierra Nevada mountains up
they found her what who are they
vultures I've seen him around Claire and
Owen mount a rescue mission to save them
tracking them to Malta where they meet
cargo pilots Caleb Watts who agrees to
fly them to the biosin facility in the
dolomites inside the facility Ellie
Allen Ian and Ramsey helped Maisie
escape and steal a locust sample in the
process Maisie reunites with her parents
and introduces them to the Jurassic Park
Legends Dr Grant
you are I'm Owen Grady big fan I read
your book
well book on tape to destroy evidence of
its attempted crimes Dodson sets fire to
the locus but the Flames engulf the
entire facility he is killed by three
Dilophosaurus before he can escape
however he leaves the mind-controlled
Giganotosaurus as a Parting Gift
thankfully Rexy is there to save the day
alongside her theraxinosaurus and the
group then rescues Wu who plans to stop
the locus Claire and Owen take Maisie
home and reunite blue with beta
meanwhile Ellie and Alan get back
together and plan to go public about
biosin the biostin valley is declared a
dinosaur Sanctuary by the United Nations
leaving the world with the formidable
task of coexisting with these
prehistoric animals
foreign